Department workshop. We will now adjourn the Housing Department budget
workshop and begin our budget workshop for the Houston Public Library.
Thank you very much.
Oh,
hello. Are you ready?
Yes, ma'am. At this time, I would like to welcome Director RIA Brown Lawson
and hope to
provide the Houston Public Library budget presentation.
The floor is yours. Thank you. And hello,
everybody. Thank you for the opportunity to present
the Houston Public Library's proposed budget for fiscal year 2023.
Before I begin, I'd like to take advantage of this opportunity
to publicly thank and acknowledge the members of the Houston Public
Library Executive Leadership Team and
other staff who are responsible for
helping the library to be one of
the best library systems in the country. So I'd
like to publicly thank and acknowledge all those members of the
executive team. It is my honor and privilege
to work with a team of professionals with such an
array of talent, innovativeness creativity, and deep commitment
to provide equitable services to the residents of our great city.
I would also like to thank and acknowledge the Houston Public Library Foundation
for their unwavering support of the library and their
support of the library's programs. Joining me
today for the presentation is the Library Department's chief
Financial officer and Assistant Director Hope Wabakesee.
With that, I will now present our proposed FY.
And if you would come a little closer to the microphone. Absolutely.
Is that better? Yes, ma'am.
Okay. Slide two presents the library's functional
organizational chart. The chart shows the distribution
of the proposed FY 23 budget and FTEs
within the six divisions of the library.
Next slide.
Slide three outlines departmental
programming and considerations relative to major services,
statutory requirements, and the financial impact
on service delivery regarding services and
programs. The library remains committed to the delivery of
equitable quality services and resources in multiple
formats to all residents of Houston through
the department's network of 38 libraries embedded
in neighborhoods throughout the city, the mobile lab
and three history research collections
and the Central Library.
Next slide.
I'm sorry. Same slide. Also in high
demand are resources for small businesses, new entrepreneurs
and job seekers. The library's network of 38 locations
throughout the city also service critical community hubs, which include
two technic facilities, three history research
centers of Texas history, african American
history and genealogical resources, with over 193
print volumes, 2500 archival
and or history collections, and 320 microform
resources per state
law. In terms of statutory requirements
per the state law, the Texas
State Library and Archives Commission, or Tslac,
sets the standards and requirements for the accreditation of
libraries throughout the state. State accreditation
eligibility requires a per capita
of 17 dollarsfifty, cents and
at least one item of library materials per
capita. The libraries per capita
for the state FY 21 annual report
was 16.90. To fill
the gap, HPL submitted supplemental
maintenance and security dollars from GST for the
last two years as part of the support for library
operations to help meet the Tslac
accreditation requirements. With the
budget increase this year, we should be poised to meet state accreditation
standards during the next reporting period.
Financial or societal impact of the City service
delivery includes 1.4
million cardholders have access to 3 million print
and digital resources. In a world where
having technological access is a basic necessity,
the library is the largest provider of free Internet access
in the region. Through their neighborhood libraries,
Houston residents have access to WiFi,
hotspots, tablets and computers.
According to the Texas State Library, for every
one dollars invested in public libraries
in Texas, the community sees a return
of approximately $5.
Anticipated growth or reduction of population
served in FY 23.8 million
people utilize the library in person or via the website.
With Houston's growth in current user demand requiring more
robust Eservices and programs, we have seen marked
increase in digital services, which is up currently.
28% from FY 2020 database
use increased 41% last year,
especially the use of Linda.com, where users
access instructive videos to
build creativity and business skills to achieve
personal and professional goals. This increased demand is
particularly impactful to the department's budget,
as databases and electronic resources are
very much more costly than print materials.
Slide Four this
slide provides an overview of the department's revenues from FY
21 actual to FY 23 anticipated
revenues. The library is not a revenue
generating department, but it does contribute to the
General Fund through passport Services and the
central library parking garage.
The Historic Preservation Fund generates revenue for the Julia Addison
Building, which is used to support the special maintenance
that is required for this historic building.
The special revenue fund is associated with the
Mayor's Office for Adult Literacy.
Next slide.
Slide five provides revenue highlights.
We anticipate returning to pre pandemic operations
in FY 23, which will contribute to an increase in
the revenue generated from the Passport services fees.
The increase in facility rental fees is
mainly due to the Frenchies restaurant rental for Smith
Library parking. The grant transfer
is a onetime FEMA insurance allocation to reimburse
Kendall library books and materials that were lost due to
Hurricane Harvey.
Next slide the library's
expenditures for FY 23 reflect an increase of
13.7% based on
mandatory salary and benefit increases
and an increase in the books and materials budget.
The Historic Preservation Fund expenditures do
not affect the General Fund as rental revenues
cover expenditures for improvement in historical maintenance
of the Julia Odds building.
Next slide.
Slide seven outlines the FY 2023
expenditure highlights. For personnel services,
there was a 3% hope increase fringe benefit increase
minimum wage increase, an additional 29
positions for staff two staff,
two new library buildings, a leaf and Dr.
Shannon Walker and the Kendall Renovated library.
FY 23 will be the first time in several
years that we will have all HPL locations open
and fully operational, requiring an increase in staffing.
The increase in supplies and services will be used
in the libraries just mentioned. The budget also
reflects an increase in the restricted accounts.
The 1.7 million increase in books and materials
relates back to the one time FEMA insurance allocation that
covers Kindle library books and materials,
an improved increase of 1 million that would allow
HPL to meet the Texas State Library accreditation
standards. Next slide.
The primary drivers in library expenses are
personnel and materials. Personnel expenses
for the library represents 72% of our total budget,
and the nonpersonal budget is 28% of
the nonpersonal budget. Non capital books and materials represent
46%, restricted accounts,
25%. Services represent 22%,
and supplies represent 2%.
Next slide.
Slide nine shows our operating budget of
30.4 million, with restricted accounts totaling
13.6 million. The contracted
and mandated adjustments total 1.5 million.
Our proposed FY 23 budget is 50,000,000.342,
which reflects a change of 14.1%.
Next slide. The chart on
slide ten represents the library's history of being good
stewards of the allocated funds the department receives.
Next slide. This concludes
my formal presentation, and I'd like to point out that the
appendix contains the library's workplace
analysis, including staff numbers and demographic
information, departmental accomplishments for FY
22, and restricted account details.
I'm happy to answer any questions that you may have.
Thank you, Director, for your presentation. We will now take questions from council
members who will each receive two minutes per the normal committee rules.
First in the queue is vice mayor pro TEM martha castex tate.
Director Lawson, thank you for your presentation. You know, I love the library
and all that you all stand for, and all that we do in the city
of Houston, especially around adult literacy.
Super excited about the Dr. Shannon Walker Library coming
to District K soon. Based on your stat
on page three, we should see a big return in
societal impact in District K
with the new library coming on board. But my question
is, can you talk a little bit about the revenues
from the passport services as we look at our
budget and how we can increase revenues in the city? I was intrigued
at our meeting that we have four or five passport
offices in libraries. I'd be
happy to pre pandemic. We were
providing million dollars worth of passport
services through the city, through five locations. Five locations?
Yes, and we anticipate
they're very popular. Let me just say we're better than the
post office. You can quote me on that. And we have
many people complimenting
our staff on the process, so they like to use the
library, and during our discussion council
Member you're wondering why we don't do it in more locations and
generate more money. And our conversation accounted
with. Well, if we do more locations, maybe the library can keep
half and the city can get half. So a million
apiece. We'll do ten locations.
Okay.
Would you need additional staff? If we put five more passport
offices in five libraries, will we need additional
staff, or would staff be able to cover that, will we be able to
see a bigger gain, or would we need to actually hire
additional staff for that running of five additional passport
offices? I think we would definitely need more staff.
We did five more locations. We'd need at
least five more staff members, but they would pay for themselves with
a million dollar five
passport offices. We've generated a million dollars through
the revenues we have.
Okay. And that money went back to the general fund and not to the
library. Every cent went back to the
general fund. Okay. Council Member Robinson.
Thank you. Chair and Director, thank you so much for all you
do with such limited number of staff.
It's really, truly remarkable. So I want to thank your team personally for that.
And of course, you and I are also working on what we hope will be
a map archive for the Julietison Library downtown.
So referring to that same chart of revenues that
the Vice Mayor Pro TEM referred to on page four,
that category of special revenue fund, while we're talking about
it and thinking in particular about the Julia Idison I know
it's come to my attention that that is the number one venue
in what, the city for weddings.
Help me with this director. We are rated on
a national scale of being the top ten places
for holding weddings. Yes. Okay,
so that's top ten in the United States of America.
Absolutely. Okay, so while we're talking about passports,
let's talk about people getting married at libraries. I love that.
Let's do that. Just for the record, I am a single
man, but I know that's beside the point. We'll hold a spot.
How much money you got? Says the vice member.
Yeah. Another aside, but it
does raise the question about potential
revenue sources for our beautiful facilities. Because whether it's
the new library that's going into District K, whether it's the
incredible facility that's going into District F on the West Side,
our flagship libraries that
are downtown and the ones that we know are most used
whether those funds go back into the general revenue fund or
how else we categorize those revenues, I'd be
really interested, because it strikes me that what we
do, as Vice Mayor Pro TEM pointed out, for societal
impacts, that is really something that
you'd think could fuel some staffing and fuel
some activities throughout the city. If you cared to comment,
we'd love to hear from you. Sure. And we're
really excited about all our historical buildings,
and with the right amount of staff and
promotion, we assure that we could generate even
more activity around them. But you're
only able to do that based on your capacity to do
it. And so you would need, like, any other
venue staffing around that.
That would be the answer. Capacity is everything,
right? And again, with the great resignation chair, that's going to be a
challenge for this department. Like every other one we've heard from today, but thank
you, director. You're welcome. Council member came in. Thank you,
Dr. Lawson. First off, we love our libraries.
Thank you to the entire team.
Can you say it one more time? When it came to Internet,
as a provider of Internet accessibility,
did you say that our libraries are the largest provider
in the region? In the region, yes.
And given the digital
divide that we saw during the
Pandemic, especially with students and youth that did
not have access to Internet, I'm assuming that those programs are continuing
beyond the Pandemic. Oh, yes. What we did during the Pandemic
was to install high powered antennas
on several of our locations so that those
families that did not have Internet access
could, at least from our parking lots with libraries closed,
have that kind of access. And some of them
were strong enough to bleeding to the homes that were nearby.
But broadband is a national
issue, as we all know, and having access
to the Internet is now like having
electricity in your home. It's a necessity because
if you don't have it, you are cut off from a lot of information that's
needed. We see people using libraries to apply
for jobs to hold. They rent out spaces
so that they can hold job interviews, because most job interviews
now are online. We see
number of citizens borrowing hotspots so
that they can take that hotspot into their home and have Internet
access. All that we're doing,
and we're doing a lot, it's a drop in the bucket for
the whole conversation around broadband and its necessity.
Maybe place back in queue. Go ahead. Thank you,
and I appreciate that. And all the efforts to confirm
all of the libraries are now back up and running that were
prior to the Pandemic. So they're open for all.
And I'm asking because we're coming up on Summer, where our libraries again
play that really important role out of school to
keep children sharp during
the summer. They engage in summer reading.
And yes, our libraries will be open for those
activities to keep their minds active
through having fun. Through reading and having fun
and library programs during the summer because
there is national research
that shows that kids that are not engaged during the summer do
lose as much as a grade level and it
provides a safe place for them to be sometimes. The last
two other questions I had really quickly. One, do all of our libraries
provide printing and scanning services currently for
the public? Scanning, like scanning
digital paper copies that they may need to be scanned,
but also printing services? I'm not
sure if all of them do, a number of them
do. I can get that answer to you. I would just
be interested in the cost breakdown of what that is. I know I've
been looking in the district if there's something that needs to be supplemented out of
district service funds for printing,
oftentimes, again,
for those that may not be able to afford it. Right. Those people that are
trying to apply for a job and may need just those few extra dollars,
those types of needs. I'm just trying to explore that.
Printing is everywhere. Scanning. That's what
I'd have to check on. Okay, I would appreciate that. And lastly,
due to the financial constraints that the city continues to face
throughout every single department, what are the needs
that you foresee for the most immediate and long term future that
we are not able to meet right now that you want us to be focused
on? What I'd like to
say as a reply to that question
to all council members is to appreciate
what the Houston Public Library is able to provide
for our citizens. But when you look at
our bottom line budget,
our bottom line budget, even with the increase
this year, is a far cry for even Chicago's
Public Library. That serves 4.6
million people with a budget of 100,000,003.
And our budget is at 50 million.
So you can see the difference.
So that would be it. The more money we have in our budget,
the more we can continue to provide services.
We staff our facilities at the bare minimum,
except for those that are the busiest. And I
think that's where the community is being shortchanged.
Because we had more robust staff, we certainly could
provide more services.
Thank you for that presentation and those answers. We'll now move
into the public comment period. The first public
speaker will be Mr. Jason Oliver.
Hi. I love the library.
I really appreciate everything that you all do.
I just want to start off saying that. Thank you. Thank you so much.
First. I know. The Harris County Library system
has rolled out the enhanced ID program this year. I actually
tried to use mine to come in. I don't know why
we need an ID to come into this building, but I tried to use it
and wasn't allowed. So I hope that that can change, because that's
a really important program. But I wanted to ask if HPL
is planning to join that and what will be needed for HPL to be able
to do that. So that's my first question.
And then second, it's often hard to find books by local
authors in the library's collections. How could we create a
program or initiative focused on acquiring the works of
local authors? So, first, that enhanced ID program, and then second,
local author acquisitions and wrapping those up?
Thank you for those questions.
In terms of enhanced ID, that's something that we can certainly
look into. We haven't had that as a priority
for the library system. We've had other priorities, but we certainly can
look into that and update you on that research.
And your second question was about local author acquisitions
and how we might be able to create, just acquire more works
by local authors. We are increasingly
focused on building our local author collection.
We have an ongoing local author display.
We have local author programs inviting
local authors to come and even participate
in workshops when experienced
local authors will give advice to those authors that
are trying to start publishing and
how to get started. So we are focused on it.
We probably need to do more promotion about that,
but we are very embracing of
local authors. Okay.
I just find it hard to find their books in the libraries and especially
in the digital collections.
Author is not a part of the permanent
library collection. Right,
and I can explain more about that. I'd be
happy to. Okay, thank you.
Stop up landing.
I just want a second appreciation for
the library. We love it. It's such a nourishing space
for the community and I love it so much. I brought my daughter and
I'm trying to talk her into speaking and asking you a question,
but for my time I have a question for you based
on your metrics. The library has a huge impact on Houstonians.
I know our family has felt that personally,
I'm curious what we know about whether library access or specific
services are equitably and how they're equitably
distributed across the city. Thank you for that
question. Our one Houston one library
master plan is based on that one word
equity. And we're looking many of the council
members have participated in seeing
that presentation of our master plan.
But it involves seven regions
and in those seven regions what we plan to do is
have similar services, if not the
exact services, similar services in each
of those regions so that people don't have to go from
one community to another unless they just want to.
But that's what we're striving to be a
city of equitable library services across the city.
I appreciate that and I love that idea. Thank you.
Geogrosal,
hi. First I want to say same thing about the library.
Actually, my number one thing I use most on my phone is my
Libby app. I love that app. It gets the most use
of everything that I use and I appreciate it. And especially since
the library has been closed, to be able to use that has been
phenomenal. So thank you. Thank you. And I also
tell everyone about it. I wanted
to ask you, are there any programs that the library I'm going to invite you
to do an ad for the library.
Somebody's going to come up to you and get that because we're looking to
have more user comments on our
library and if you found something that's really useful, I appreciate
that. I would love to do that for you. Tell me where and
when somebody approach you. Okay.
Are there any programs that the library is interested in implementing or
seeking to implement for which it doesn't currently have the necessary
funding?
How long a time do you have?
We always want to do more. We think we've hit a
good balance with understanding what the citizens of
our city want and need. We just like to do more of it.
Longer. That would require longer hours, more weekend
services, more access to the library. Okay,
well, let me know how I can help. All right. Somebody approach you?
Roderick Butler. We're getting Sunday coming
soon. Didn't say that,
Director. I stand with all
of these people that we would be wherever,
do whatever, because thank you.
You are a treasure. Libraries provide a
safety net for communities, for our children,
for our adults, and they are
there in our good, our bad, and sometimes they're just there,
and that's all it requires. But I would like to
ask you about my community. There is a little library
called Scenic Wood Regional Library. We would love this
may be a CIP issue to expand the footprint of that library.
Basically, the capacity. It has land to the north
of it vacant. It has land to the south of it. It's forest,
but it's still vacant. There are other libraries like
Dixon Library, which is new. We would love to expand the footprint of that.
I don't even know if Lakewood Library has come back online,
but we need to know,
do you have any plans for new libraries in the future
in your master plan? How do we get it? How do we support you,
and how do we give input for it? We would
love to have your input with
our planning for library
spaces and understand better what the
needs are. We have a good sense. We know that
there are communities that need more.
We do understand that. What I answered
about services is all about capacity.
It's about our CIP. It's about having
enough funding to go around. And I meant what
I said about equity. We're looking at each area of the city
and seeing how we can be a
more equitable department in terms of
providing services, if not
right away, a larger footprint, at least the services
in those areas. Well, my heart is full and know
that this is your army. Yes, it is. So you just call upon
us, all right? Because we've all been
in a library, and it has
benefited us. So please know that. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Vice Mayor Pro TEM Cassex Taylor. Thank you. I want to
close with this comment. Director Lawson.
When we were looking to build our library in District A, we had an
opportunity to take a tour of some libraries throughout the city
hosted by your staff, and we've had
quite a few residents from District B to
talk about their concerns. But I will tell you,
this is one area where I can tell you firsthand
that District B is shining bright, because we
got to visit the library and saw the tech link and
all the technology in the library in District
B. And I will tell you, I was like, I want all that
in our new library in District K too. So I hear
you when you talk about equity and you talk about making
sure that our communities that
have found themselves many times to be maybe
not having the same level of resources that the library
has walked the walk. And the resources that are available
in the libraries in District B were phenomenal
when we were there on the tour. So thank you for caring about
the citizens of Houston and making sure that we
all have access to great quality libraries
throughout the city of Houston. We appreciate all that you do.
This is probably the happiest budget amendment I mean,
budget session of all of the ones that we'll hear over this
week. So we appreciate all the work that you do. Did you say amendment?
I have amendment on my mind because I'm thinking about those passports.
Thank you. I really appreciate all the support that all of
you give to the library.
Daughter Blending, did you want to sign up to speak?
I like the audiobooks that the libraries provide,
and I want more of those for
the libraries.
We hear you. Which library is your library?
Stonica Library. All right.
More audiobooks.
We'll try to accommodate your request.
Thank you.
Council member Cayman. Council member Cayman. Miss Blanding,
I just wanted to say you did a really good job. You're probably one of
the youngest people we've ever had speak at Budget,
and you were awesome.
And thank you for speaking up about audiobooks. We were debating
that, I think, a few council sessions ago about the importance
of audiobooks. So really, thank you for making such a difference.
Thank you for your presentation. There are no additional in person
or virtual speakers before we
wrap up. Really say thank you not only to the director, but your entire
staff, the entire team, all of you, all who work within the library
department. We understand that budgets are tight,
and you all make the best of what you can with the resources that you
have. There are people all over the city who truly
value, and the contributions you make to us
are greatly appreciated. I think I heard you by saying there are 1.4
million cardholders. Yes. That's incredible.
We're rolling up on 2 million. So that's incredible. So thank
you all for everything that you do. Before we adjourn,
please note that the budget workshops will continue to tomorrow,
Tuesday, May 17, at 10:00 A.m., with general services.
Reminder to all council members to be checking SharePoint for
uploaded presentations as well as responses for any questions
submitted. Thank you again to everyone for being here today, and this meeting
is adjourned.
Thank you.